welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousin sitting in for david
pakman today and hey don't forget you
can find me on all my social media
accounts twitter facebook and instagram
same name on all of them at
farren
balanced that is also the name of my
personal youtube channel and of course
you can find me at youtube.com slash the
ring of fire
let's talk about the january 6 select
committee to round out this day's show
right
after all
it now appears they're going after
sitting republican members of congress
they submitted a request this week to
republican congressman scott perry and
perry made headlines recently when it
was revealed that he was one of the
i guess you'd call it a ringleader
of some of the other house republicans
who were working to get the doj
to intervene and overturn the results of
the 2020 presidential election scott was
kind of the ringleader
and now mr perry
after
the committee said we would like some
documents from you and of course we
would like for you to sit down and have
a chat with us
has announced that no not gonna do it
because he says
the committee is somehow illegitimate
and unconstitutional
let me read this statement that perry
put out on tuesday
after deciding he was not going to
work with the committee
i stand with immense respect for our
constitution the rule of law and the
americans i represent who know that this
entity is illegitimate and not duly
constituted under the rules of the us
house of representatives
i decline this entity's request and will
continue to fight the failures of the
radical left who desperately seek
distraction from their abject failures
of crushing inflation a humiliating
surrender in afghanistan and the
horrendous crisis they created at our
border
sometimes folks sometimes
there's so much stupid
in one statement
that it hurts it hurts us to read these
things
it's painful
to have those words come out of my mouth
even if they're not from me they're from
him i don't like that at all
so
let's address a couple things real quick
here from mr perry
you're calling the democrats
losers you're saying they can't get over
something dude the reason they want to
talk to you in the first place is
because you tried to overturn the
election
you tried to weaponize the department of
justice
to do your bidding and illegally
unconstitutionally by the way since you
seem to love the constitution
overturned the duly elected government
of the united states at the time so you
don't get to lecture anyone about what
is and is not constitutional
and of course yes the select committee
is 100 constitutional that was actually
something i had discussed in yesterday's
program as well
you know with alex jones lawsuit saying
the committee is not constitutional no
it is
courts have ruled over the years yes the
house of representatives does in fact
have this authority uh going all the way
back to the first
uh basically criminal inquiry i guess
you could call it that the house
conducted all the way back in 1795.
so
learn your history scott perry
learn your supreme court cases
congressman perry
so that you won't make such a damn fool
of yourself in the future
but it is what it is right mr perry's
doing what he knows he's worried he's
panicked he understands that the text
messages that have already come out from
him are really really bad and the
committee is doing what they should be
doing and now officially focusing on
these members of congress
the problem that i have
with them going after these members of
congress because let's not forget jim
jordan
is also involved in this uh gomert
brooks
all of these people do need to be
investigated they do need to be called
in front of the committee but that's not
enough heck we also need to find out why
lauren bobert was you know live-tweeting
nancy pelosi's
location during all of this
she'd only been a member of congress for
at that point really a matter of hours
so why was she doing that so that also
needs to be brought up in front of the
committee the problem i have
is that that's not good enough
just bringing these people in front of
the committee getting your hands on
these records you know their call logs
text messages whatever it is and getting
their testimony
we've seen
a lot of this already
the problem is even if you get horrible
information on any of these individuals
the most you can do is recommend
criminal charges for them you're not
going to vote to expel them
and even if you attempted to vote to
expel them you wouldn't have the votes
to do it
that's what drives me crazy about all of
this
because these members of congress do
need to be expelled
it is time for that
yes we can go through due process we'll
make sure it's all fair and neat you
know cross our t's dot our eyes all of
that
but if you ask me personally right now i
think these people need to be expelled
i think their actions based on the text
messages that again are already readily
available
i think they rise to sedition i think
they rise to treason
we are talking about elected members of
congress
trying to convince the department of
justice to overturn
what effectively was the government
elect
of the united states
there's no ifs ands or buts about it
really when you look at it that way
that would constitute treason
even trying to tell them
to do these things
would likely rise to the level of
sedition
so how are these people still serving in
congress
the answer is
the republicans
if the democrats had the numbers i would
like to think they would go ahead and
vote to expel these members
right i'd like to think that
heaven only knows sometimes what the
democrats are actually going to do
but without those republican numbers
it's not going to happen
without enough republicans standing up
and saying this person is so toxic
not just to my party
but to the country itself and i believe
that their behavior does rise to the
level of criminal activity and i want
them gone without enough republicans to
say that it's not going to happen
and then of course maybe
we get charges referred
from this and then maybe
these people get prosecuted and maybe
they get convicted
at this point we're talking about four
or five years out into the future
probably at that point
you know they can serve another what
two and a half terms
in the amount of time that may take
think of the damage that these
individuals could do in that time
it's not good enough
letting them sit there while this
happens is not good enough at the very
least we need some kind of mechanism to
where they could at least be suspended
and i know there is currently no
mechanism like that in the house
maybe that's something we work on maybe
that's an amendment to the constitution
maybe we throw that in with the term
limit
amendment that i also feel we
desperately need
but until this matter is settled until
these people cooperate and turn over
everything and the committee finishes
its work and issues its final report
these individuals should have their
votes suspended
they should be stripped of their
committees immediately
and that should be that
that's what we should do
but again there's no constitutional
mechanism for that to happen
so we need an amendment
to give congress the authority to do
that i believe i don't think they could
just change their own rules to do that
so that's what needs to happen